love this guy's so thrilled that he's
gonna be sitting next to me in the NFL
Network Scouting Combine booth for an
absurd amount of hours next weekend in
the first-ever primetime version of the
NFL Scouting Combine on NFL Network he
is a longtime Scout and individual and
observer of this league it has been
dynamite for all of us at NFL Network
for Wow the last eight years Daniel
Jeremiah good to see you sir are you
doing but how much how many people have
you watched tape on I'm at 337 some of
those aren't come on guys I've got about
10 10 to 12 safeties left to do then I'm
done with everybody in the economy is
that right yeah it's my forearm hurts
man I didn't know what it was and I was
talking to my buddies in the league is
it offensive line coach yeah you got a
clicker forearm there you know that's
almost gosh there apparently it's it's
like an ergonomically incorrect
situation for people with who time too
many individuals an invention out there
we can save for arms around the league I
just don't know do I need to look for
somebody to replace you for my from my
40 it's it's early in the week we don't
have to put on an injury report yet okay
[Music]
so your your probable your probable well
looks pretty much ok very good all right
let's get into this thing here because
Thursday night one week from tonight can
we quarterbacks a prime time they've
reconfigured everything around
television is beginning to take over
this event you've got TV creep on this
event no appetite it's just we're
jumping around that is the biggest night
of watching television we all know that
and so just jump right in right now with
with quarterbacks what are you hearing
about Joe burrow is there any smoke to
the story the rumor that gets bigger
that to be very honest a lot of his
answers to questions fuels that he
doesn't want to play for the Bengals
that he's gonna pull in Eli Manning what
are you hearing
well first of all I went last week I
went and spent time with him and watched
him throw and then visit with him for
about 20-25 minutes where was this well
he's with Jordan Palmer at Jay Sarah
high school Sam Darnell down there Josh
Allen's down there Kyle Allen's down
there so he was down there working out
with those guys so Jordan
the one who is the connection a lot of
people have made with Carson his
experience with the Bengals you know
who's working on the receivers right and
he has basically said something similar
what Carson Palmer has said so that's
why people are connected correct and he
hasn't he hasn't gone out and eliminated
it with with what he said so you know I
we didn't talk specifically about that
but I would just kind of reading between
the lines say he's just kind of in a
little bit of a fact-finding mission
here to find out what this is gonna be
so fact what's what facts I kind of
solve it real quick sure if I'm the
Cincinnati Bengals and whether or not
you think this is real this may happen
this may not happen free agency starts
March 18th go out and sign Joe Tunney or
go out and sign a free agent and say
we're committed we want to win
championships we are going to spend the
money to surround you with the support
that you need and that's like it's like
a good-faith gesture there to say this
is you know hey we want to win a
championship and here's some examples of
that
so the Bengals need to make free agency
maneuvers to make an overture to
somebody that they could take any way
they could but then he has you know he
mentioned the word leverage which he
does have which sounds weird to people
the draft you have no leverage well no
you do if you're willing if you're
willing to go to ought to be a grad
assistant for a year because he's out of
eligibility so that's what I'm saying
you just sit for the year so I've said
it's a nuclear option I don't think I
don't think we're gonna get there I
think he'll be the first pick I think
you'll be with the Bengals and all this
stuff will go away I'm just saying if
you're if you're the Bengals and you
want to say we've got some pretty good
pieces in place here offensively in my
opinion it's the best offense a number
one pick would jump into since cam went
to Carolina at that Carolina team okay
because that Carolina team you when you
look at who they had was Jordan gross
Ryan clay obviously our Steve Smith yet
DeAngelo Williams yet yet Johnathan
Stewart that was really good group but I
would take the talent that Cincinnati
has coming back provided they're healthy
with Jonah Williams coming back and with
AJ green coming back I think there's
more talent around him than all these
recent number one picks that they've
walked into so and what about Zach
Taylor I mean he's no slouch right I
mean we
we saw last year was troubling obviously
once again where the Bengals found a
floor that we didn't think that they
would hit so is bar I mean
borough should be a fit anywhere but the
question is is how would that work I
mean what what could be possibly in
Burroughs thinking outside of the fact
the Bengals of the Bengals and we've
seen what the Bengals can be in Carson's
telling Jordan and I'm sure Carson said
time with him basically say bro my
experience with this guy in Mike Brown
and what an actor was this what what
about the X's and O's and fit I think if
I think the fit can work now one of the
things that was act Taylor is they'll do
a lot of under Center stuff and boot and
stretch the Kyle Shanahan offense that
he's kind of come up in with Jill burrow
I'm parking him in the shotgun I'm
getting in I'm getting four in five guys
out in the route which is what he
excelled that at LSU and Zack smart
enough yeah he's gonna you're gonna
draft him you know what he can do you're
gonna put him in that situation so I
have any reservations about that I think
when you look at maybe some of his
concern Joe burrows 23 years old rich
he's not old enough to have been alive
when the when the Bengals want a playoff
game so while he's a hometown guy two
hours away
they haven't had that success I think
they've averaged like less than seven
wins a season since 1993 or whatever it
is they haven't gone out and spent money
and free agency so those are kind of the
factors I think way into this I don't
think has anything to do with the with
the coach I don't think it has anything
to do with the players they have their
cuz I think there's a good nucleus to
build around Daniel Jeremiah here on the
Rich Eisen shows but let's play this
thing out just for you know what some
giggles and by the way this might be
just a instead of the conversation you
and I are gonna have at the pre combine
meeting on Wednesday we'll just hash it
out right here who would be the other
team in and what are the quarterback in
if this is an Eli man anything who would
be the Phillip Rivers in this who would
be the team that would call up the
Bengals and say okay which quarterback
do you want let's make that trade who
would be the Giants and the Philip
Rivers in this equation if this is in
fact the Eli Manning and the Chargers
between burrow and the Bengals well if
we're gonna go with that
you know comparison I think you're
talking about to uh you know you have to
take to a red shirt to a and that would
be you know you're talking about the
team with the ammunition to get up
there's the Dolphins that's the one that
makes sense but then you've got seven
with Joe Brady
with the Carolina Panthers what would
you would think would be more than
willing to make a bold move to try and
go all the way up there they'd have to
do that so Williams time away that's a
long way for them to go I almost feel
like if you're if you're if if I'm the
Bengals and in the word just really
playing this thing out that's what we're
doing but if I'm the Bengals and I get
you know wind of it that he's not gonna
show up then we decide organizationally
we're gonna try and get the most we can
for this pick
I'm not gonna get out a range of the
next quarterback so I would be I would
say look the Lions are picking at three
so if you're five six and seven which
are the three quarterback teams the
Dolphins the Chargers the Panthers you
got it before you get to me you got to
go through Detroit because you're gonna
have to get to the third pick because
we're not gonna go further than the
third pick that's where that's where we
stop so you're gonna have to do a trade
to get to three before you can even get
to me and that's gonna be incredibly
expensive so do you think the Dolphins
have already reached out to the lines
have you heard that that they that
they've already reached out I haven't
heard that yet it's early it's so early
in the process in Indianapolis I think
is when you'll start hearing some of
those well that's the reason why I'm
asking this because if if I'm the
Dolphins and I do love to as much as we
all assume that they do once two hits
Indy and everybody gets to actually see
him talk to him mm-hmm take him in see
his medical perhaps be as positive as it
is don't you think there's gonna be
others that'll be knocking on the line
store at 3:00 saying I want him I mean
don't you think it'll be more so you
might as well go and try and get him now
in the same way that Washington knocked
on less needs door for rg3 way way in
advance yeah but I think the injury
changes all that I mean you can't you
there's no way in your right mind that
you can make that trade without your
doctors getting their hands on him and
Singh first hand what this looks like
this is not a standard ACL this is not
somebody who broke his leg right it's a
hip and that's scary it's it that's it's
a really scary injury so and it's all
different I mean I there's a documentary
I've talked to some teams about this
there's a documentary on Andy Murray the
tennis player
who was number one in the world when he
has his hip injury he's playing doubles
now he never was able to regain
what he had he's just trying to manage
the pain and all the issues that he's
had that he's had so hips are different
and I think you've got to get your
medical people and I wouldn't even
that's why I think that trade might even
be you know go beyond a little bit later
than we would think because I want to
get the latest medical information on to
I as I can before you make them what do
you make of the Armando Segura or poured
out of Miami then that Miami's like you
know what we like this Herbert kid maybe
more than we like to what do you think
of that I mean I don't doubt that
there's somebody there's people in the
organization that might like Herbert
anything that gets out right now it gets
out for a reason you know it is I mean
and that's like Detroit right Detroit
what were we saying at the end of the
season the trade pick is three it's
obvious that's the trade pick you got to
get to three if you want to uh and
you've got five six and seven they need
to get the three well now a sudden they
might now they're let getting it out
there it's out there everywhere we like
to it we're into tua aka it's gonna cost
you a little more and certainly the the
fact that the Dolphins have accrued so
much Drath capital you're gonna out
you're gonna hold them up for as much as
you possibly can if you Detroit here's
the here the the I feel like we do this
every year because you're always it's
always the the grass is greener on the
other side right there's the presence of
Lawrence that kind of hangs out there of
people Stryver Lawrence Trevor Lawrence
if San I'm not gonna go all the way in
right now I'm if we can get a deal that
works we'll do it but with Trevor
Lawrence and then you've got the kid at
Ohio State and believe it or not there's
a quarterback at North Dakota State next
year that's gonna probably come out
twenty eight touchdowns no picks this
year is an unbelievable athlete he teams
love him what's his name that's where
I'll get to once I get these three
hundred North look him up look him up
the North Dakota State quarterback they
won the national champion
he's 6-3 225 pounds he did throw an
interception the whole season I don't
know the last time I've ever seen
anything right yeah but what I'm getting
at you've got three really interesting
quarterbacks in next year's class prey
Lance tre Lance there you go get to know
that name I'm talking to myself going on
that's why teams I think would be
reluctant to really go all on the team
that makes the most sense to make that
type of a holy cow they just gave up all
that right is Carolina so before we dig
into actual prospects in the actual
combine let's just finish this
conversation up right here and right now
with with all of what we're talking
about Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich
Eisen show if Trevor Lawrence is in this
draft where does he go
Oh he'd go number one number one yeah
you didn't even Sutter Joe borough just
had the season he just had Joe Broz I
love Joe borough but Trevor Lawrence has
more ability you know so he would be the
first pick no doubt you don't even
stutter I don't have any doubt why now
we'll see what happens as we go through
the next year yeah he's rich he's he's
six foot six you saw the way he can run
I mean he's gonna when he I tweeted that
we're staying there right now on the
screen the this run where he ran away
from the entire the Ohio State defense I
tweeted out that half the league just
tanked for that for the 2021 draft well
the genius of that play is about two
minutes before that I tweeted they need
to stop running Lawrence he's going to
get killed
as you can imagine Twitter was very kind
to me I'm sure yeah okay
Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show best prospect in the draft is chase
Young okay didn't starter there either
so then why wouldn't Cincinnati take him
well that's the thing is that if if
there is you know whatever happens with
burrow what happens but it's not I mean
that's not the worst thing in the world
you end up taking a you know an
unbelievable talent at the second most
important position on the field and
chase Young who also happens to be gonna
be a very popular player in the in the
state there everybody watched him play
throughout his college career but you
still quarterback trumps everything so
even though he's a he's carries a higher
grade than somebody like Jill burrow you
got to take the quarterback if you've
got a chance to take the quarterback
okay and then the best other prospect
not a quarterback would be who I
probably Derek brown from from Auburn
he's he's in Dominic ensues who he
reminds me of he's just a dominant
dominant player I think he's better than
Quintin Williams who was coming into
last year's draft so he's uh you know
he's he's a he's just a physical freak I
was talking to a GM the other day we're
talking about a guard I think was LSU
guard and Lewis and I said hey do you
like him he goes mad just I didn't
really want
up to him I go you watch the Auburn game
because yeah I just watch think like he
does that to everybody
Derrick Brown does that to everybody go
watch more of the LSU card because don't
penalize him for what that kid did the
one okay in the deepest position group
that we're gonna see at the combine with
wide receivers yeah it's ridiculous
ridiculous
why how so just the depth now there's
not a Calvin Johnson there's not a Julio
Jones but there are I mean I think I
think I've got like 181 20 21 to 23
receivers with top three round grades
now I'm not saying they're all gonna go
in the in the first three rounds but
that's how many talented players you
have there and there's every every kind
of wide receiver that you could ever
want yeah I could see here I've got your
top 50 that you updated about a week ago
that's coming out I'll have an update
it'll I turn in tomorrow probably post
Monday okay so on nfl.com guys to daniel
jeremiah here you've got CD lamb over
Jerry Judy but they're eight nine
they're right next time sure that's
whatever flavor you want what's the
flavor difference the flavor difference
is Jerry Judy's gonna give you more
separation
Jerry Judy probably give you a little
bit more over the top and CD lamb is is
a better contested catch guy CD lamps is
an animal after the catch so those are
the two different styles those guys and
you got Henry rugs the third at 12 on
your Disick in your top 20 yeah
the receiver from Alabama I'm gonna run
for to something Justin Jefferson it's
17 the wide receiver from LSU who
catches everything right in an Arizona
State senior Brandon yuke yuke is 19
brain and I you rich talk he's been
working with Houshmandzadeh and
Houshmandzadeh said he's the closest
thing to Chad Johnson that he's seen
since Chad Johnson and then we're just
talking here about top 20 you've got
Jordan loves sitting there above Justin
Herbert yeah but I'd look there's I
think there's kind of this you know
thought out there that it's Justin
Herbert is lightyears ahead of him and
for me he's not I think the 2018 version
of Jordan love is better than any
version of Justin Herbert that I've seen
now Jordan love took a tremendous fall
this year lost nine starters head coach
offensive coordinator
um and he just turned the ball over way
too much and that's something you've got
to try and figure out but it's just a
natural thrower of the football I mean
he is he's explosive he can move around
he's he's as talented as anybody at the
position he's just not ready tried to go
play a game tomorrow Justin Herbert if I
can redshirt these guys for a little bit
and then look into the future I think
Jordan Love has more there
Daniel Jeremiah are here on the Rich
Eisen show deepest defensive position
group that is well I think it's a good
group of corners I think there's a lot
of depth there you know it's funny it's
it's kind of what the games given us you
go to any high school field in the
country and you'll see spread offense
four wide receivers balls flying all
over the place seven on seven year-round
and then we come into these drafts and
go man we got tons of receivers we got
tons of DBS that says what this what
this these kids have been doing their
whole life so it makes sense the deepest
position groups of receivers and v's
there you go unbelievable and who's
gonna be the fastest rugs rugs uh you
know that the cool thing with with data
now with the GPS stuff and we use some
of it because I know we do it with run
routes run yes where you can get the mph
and all that well I think it's called
the catapult system okay so these guys
wear this you know wear this during
practice isn't during games and so when
Scouts go through there now instead of
just saying hey did this guy to run a 40
you'll say give me the what's the
catapult numbers right and the numbers
on rugs were beyond off the charts like
would have been faster than anybody on
the field last year in the NFL that's
how fast we you see 42 I don't know the
second numbers gonna be - I don't know
what the third numbers gonna be no
kidding oh yeah he could fly man so John
Ross has got to be sitting up straight
wherever he's watching the combine
Thursday night when he steps it when
drugs steps to the line and charity
stripe Thursday night man huh I mean
speaking of run right run who do I have
an opportunity to catch this year I've
got some good news bad news for you
okay good all right news makai Becton
from louisville is six foot seven 370
plus it's a big man that's a large
individuos the bad news is you can run
seven he's gonna be six seven 370 plus
and how fast is he gonna run you say you
can go five seven five six five he's
gonna go he's gonna go south of that I
believe we'll see we'll see
so the largest man it's you're gonna be
it's gonna be right here it's gonna be
the same okay that's good by the way
we've got some big run routes run news
coming at the end of the second hour of
the show where we can raise a ton of
money the best oh man I can't I can't
wait for that before I let you go you
sir are a radio analyst for the Los
Angeles chargers the the where you get
to that question which before you get to
that question can I take one charger
side note yes so I had to have a minor
procedure done right but you still get
some anesthesia so we come out of it we
get we get home and I tell my wife I
said the doctor ever come talk to us
afterwards she spent 10 minutes with us
yeah I go What did he say
she's laid out what you need to do okay
said what did I say she saw you just
looked at him and said to was going to
the Chargers there's a there's a doctor
in San Diego let's get back I've known
that for months okay you're coming out
of anesthesia and the first thing you
say that doctor is two words I have no
idea by the way I've never heard that I
know I called their games but nobody's
told me they're gonna take to uh they're
not in you know who knows but that's
what I told the guy well I mean the
Chargers sitting there at six and the
sixth player on your top 50 is - oh
maybe that's it maybe that was the
connection just like you're got my
beautiful mind thing in your in your
in your you know anesthesia hazed mind
going on the quarterback who starts the
first game for the Los Angeles Chargers
in that new stadium Phillip was on this
show two years ago said he wanted to be
that guy he's clearly not gonna be yeah
your best guess as to who that
quarterback will be well I think the
safest would probably say Tyrod Taylor
current the current currently in the
position number we assume that they
draft one and don't get one in free
agents we don't want to go safe DJ Cobb
you don't want to go say I mean look it
there's a lot of things that reasons it
makes sense for the Chargers to go after
Tom Brady didn't bring him in there and
that would be the that's the billboard I
mean that's the home run from the
billboards standpoint I'm just curious
to see what what Tom wants to do you
know I can make sense of it from the
Chargers thing all day long the question
is does it make sense for Tom so what
would make sense for Tom and I'm talking
football wise here I'm not talking about
you know whatever his family might enjoy
about living in Southern California in
Los Angeles but what would it mean I
mean there's a word Patriots still makes
the most sense to me with him but you
know could it work here
I think the Chargers have some work to
do in free agency I'm shore up that
offensive line the interesting thing is
you could make the priming detection but
I guess you could make the promise and
say look Tom we're gonna go sign one or
two and free agency we have the sixth
pick we're gonna take a lime when we can
get the best tackle on the draft with
that sixth overall pick and we know the
weapons we've got your franchise hunter
Henry bring him back Keenan Allen Mike
Williams Austin Eckler who I think way
do you see when he's the full-time back
next year what he does is gonna ease
unbelievable so now you can say Tom this
looks pretty good now but I think they
have some work to do to really sell that
hmm the issue is is what what what are
the Patriots gonna do to let Tom know
this is what we've got outside of what
we had you know you know and that needs
to be communicated in a manner that they
then it will have to go and do because
this decision has to be made right as
the new league year begins
you can't unless that mean that
tampering window if you will that they
don't want to call the tampering they
get some work done during that window
they dams raesha straight - yeah like an
absolute
possible tunnel all that one is this
carousel gonna be though I mean like I
think I think the right thing for
probably we'd want to see Tom finish up
in New England and have the derrick
jeeter
run mm-hmm but man for what we do I'd
love to see him go somewhere else a lot
of fun to talk about well DJ if I can
keep you for one more segment let's
let's hit that because it that is right
around the corner right after the
combine though this is we had shefter on
yesterday he called it the best free
agency period for quarterbacks that
we've ever seen anything like it no I
know and because there's so many names
that are out there or potentially to be
out there including Philip Rivers and I
want to hit that with Daniel Jeremiah
that's next on this edition of the Rich
Eisen show one more segment with Daniel
Jeremiah with who and I will be paired
once again in the old combine draft
double dip we'll be hanging in Vegas and
hanging in Indianapolis for an absurd
amount of time together and so why not
spend another segment with you right now
here on the Rich Eisen show so what do
you think happens with Phillip Rivers
where he's now moved to reportedly in
the around the Tampa area Tampa might be
tinkering with their quarterback who has
had LASIK to fix his 3030 vision so what
do you think DJ was toupper I think Nina
I think Mina Kimes had that tweet by the
way did she really was that is it from
3032 20/20 actually you know thirty
eight thirty thirty to forty twenty is
really what you know I'm sure Aaron's
thinks possible so I think Philips going
to the Colts I said that from from the
jump
once that news came out that he was not
gonna be coming back to the Chargers it
makes too much sense for both parties it
just does he's familiar with the offense
you want to learn a new offense this
point time your career anyways got the
offensive line that can protect you
you're gonna play nine games indoors cuz
you get one in Houston every year
minimum well with a 17 game schedule I
got to redo all this math I know a lot
of inner game is what he's gonna get so
I think it's a perfect situation for him
to go for a couple more years hmm so
then Jameis stays in Tampa yeah and
that's another component of this whole
bar
agreement because if they don't get an
agreement before the start of the league
year then the transition tag is in play
so you can franchise tag Barrett the
pass rusher Shaq Barrett and you could
transition tag which is a little bit
lower number on Jameis so you bring them
back for one year it's not as expensive
as a franchise tag other teams would
have the right to come in there and you
know offer him a bat that money I don't
know who that team would be I mean the
only the only the only team I think the
coach that would make this make sense
for him is is Gruden because Gruden
loved him going through the QB school
Jameis is unbelievable on the board and
when he's met with teams during that
process he's brilliant and he can make
every throw you can you could show
Jameis Winston's best and put it up
against everybody else the
decision-making is a major major issue
but if you're if you're conditioning
he's legitimately Jameis is the ultimate
one-armed bandit to put in Las Vegas
Nevada
are you what's the diamond diamond
derrick karr the difference they're
totally opposite like you could not be
any more polar opposite one is hyper
aggressive ones hyper conservative
I mean you mean like throwing it out of
bounds on fourth down needed score just
as an example it's an example so it
would be the it would be the classic you
you go higher the exact opposite of what
you just fired so to me that is the
opposite if it's the George Costanza do
everything opposite that would be Jameis
Winston Saints is there any and I know
Bree says I want to keep playing he's
gonna be there right story so my Drew
Brees works out at a place with Todd
Dirk and called Fitness Quest my dad my
dad would just turned 79 that's his gym
he goes in there works out all the time
and he said Brees normally really starts
coming in and April like really started
he said he's already there is ready
there I'm an animal he is an absolute
and forty so he knows he's got to take
care of his business in that regard and
so cam this is so fascinating to me some
Matt rule comes in so so David Tepper
gets the the one college coach outside
of Lincoln round that everybody thought
yeah you know it was the hottest one
there's no question Joe Brady was the
hottest assistant from college to bring
into the
two pros he's got that guy both of them
what do you do with cam I mean do you if
he they say he's gonna be healthy do you
stick with him or do you just burn it
all down and start with a young guy from
scratch that they go ahead and either
draft or require or what do you think
Carolina does I think it's I think all
options are on the table I'm fascinated
by it but I did not get the cent you
know I think the what do you say well
tell me if he's healthy we'll find out
when he's healthy what did not send me
healthy I know but that that was the
answer that said okay I don't feel great
about cam right now they're going
forward where does he go where they that
I can't figure out the only thing as we
mentioned a little bit earlier what kind
of you know what the Dolphins attempted
to do last year not to use the word if
you're gonna identify one team Hank if
you're gonna identify one team that
would make sense for and if you think
about how far Clemson is from from there
yeah that's the one team if you said
we're gonna tear this thing down to the
studs our head coaches got a seven year
contract he's gonna be here this is a
long build so tank for Trevor right next
door has a better ring to it it sure
does
how about that one Christopher you like
that one so then where does Cam go like
that Chicago is not doing anything right
no I don't know where he would go I go
that Chicago is the one team that I
mentioned you know if you but you're
totally you're not saying you're coming
in here to compete you're saying MIT the
true Biscay things over life you do that
outside of Brady the only other
quarterback that would I think capture
the Los Angeles fancy or that my
children who I used as a as a again it's
in a crucial example I know that there
are 11 eight and nine and six and they
don't have any buying purchasing power
but they they are indicative of so many
people in this town that would want to
go to games and take the kids to games
yeah if cam shows up here at starpower
you got to have it yeah I'm Los Angeles
no that's theirs that's a legitimate
case to be made there I'm just curious
to see there's two things one is he
healthy okay assuming he's healthy then
mmm
how does he want to play because if I'm
gonna bring in Cam Newton I'm hoping I'm
getting the Cam Newton I can run some
quarterback power with and I can I can
let him run I think
that's that's two there's two different
Cam Newton's you know there's the pure
pocket only Cam Newton or there's the
MVP Cam Newton so that to me you got to
figure out what you're getting well
Daniel I'm gonna take the same approach
with you of timing my 44 run rich run
i'ma have to see how healthy ER and when
new as we get close you just have to
keep me apprised as to whether your
timing arm is already your forearms or
tooth time too many guys and you've got
that sort of atrophy that's happening
here I don't want to do a disservice to
your run and I need every help I can
every second I cannot above that I'm not
I'm not one of these guys gonna hurt the
team going out there not being healthy
HiFi can't go we'll get some there is an
eye and Daniel and Jeremiah but you're a
great teammate thanks for coming on here
DJ move the sticks check out his podcast
with Bucky Brooks and check him out on
Twitter and Instagram and check him out
with me on NFL Network next week in
prime time one week from tonight for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on be our live or download the Rich
Eisen show app